this video is sponsored by Squarespace
this video is going to be something
rather different a little more ambitious
than my usual content perhaps a thought
adventure and one that might instill a
little existential dread you have been
forewarned dear viewer we're going to
try and tease apart the very nature of
what it is to be human and in so doing
we're going to try and understand a bit
more about the very Universe we occupy
why on a fitness channel are we doing
this
first this isn't a fitness channel it's
a human performance channel the bioneer
has always been about exploring and
pushing the boundaries of The Human
Condition
second because getting the most from our
bodies and Minds means first
understanding them and how they tick
and third Because deep thinking and
exploring mind-bending Concepts is good
for that very brain development I hope
this might Inspire similar deep thinking
as a disclaimer I must say this isn't
necessarily what I believe to be true it
comes from lots of studies and Concepts
I've read about then I'm just playing
around with those I'm really sharing my
thoughts and ideas surrounding the
biggest thought experiment
who are we
to better understand what a human is we
should maybe try and create one create
life
as you do hypothetically of course how
might we go about this well we could
start by trying to code a human brain we
can't build a living tissue but we can
create a simulation of a person at least
in theory maybe we should start with
something a bit simpler like a worm or a
fly what if we created a physics engine
and then programmed every single cell in
a simple creature's body to behave just
as it does in real life
surely it would then be alive or is
there something special about having a
physical form
it might sound like science fiction this
is very much something that scientists
are doing right now as far back as 2005
IBM's blue Brain Project simulated half
a mouse's brain on the blue jean
supercomputer in 2013 German scientists
were already running simulations of one
percent of a human brain that simulation
modeled 1.73 billion nerve cells and
10.4 trillion synapses using the K
computer at the time the fourth fastest
supercomputer in the world
these simulations literally code for
each neuron and then have the neurons
fire as they would in a real creature
simulating life the spawn model is based
on human brain principles and uses 2.5
million simulated neurons to perform
tasks like digit recognition list
memorization and simple arithmetic
despite not being specifically
programmed in any of these tasks
open worm is an open source science
project that aims to simulate every cell
of a worm species C elegans that grows
less than a millimeter this project
includes every single neuron and nerve
in its body every single muscle while
incomplete the worm is capable of
accurate worm-like movements within a
virtual environment
they might think that given enough
computing power and time we will find
ourselves with a fully functional human
brain at some point in the future right
well maybe not see even if we were able
to create a highly complex model of the
roughly 86 billion neurons and 100
trillion synapses we still wouldn't be
able to accurately model the way those
neurons behaved lacking processing power
which we do isn't even the biggest issue
why because we don't understand how
neural networks work not fully not even
close to be honest these models lack
glial cells the white cells of the brain
which play a number of important
functions in supporting neurons and
synapses they lack neurotransmitters
which modulate and alter the way that
brain cells behave they lack short-term
plasticity long-term plasticity rate
coding or dendritic computation that
last one explains how a single neuron is
actually capable of handling basic logic
some of these things are ideas we're
only just now exploring many aspects of
the human brain and the nature of
thought itself likely remain
undiscovered
our understanding of how the brain works
is extremely limited and even if we
could model an entire human brain it
still wouldn't operate properly without
a fully modeled human body as well and
for the neurochemistry to work as it
should we should also code the most
accurate physics engine known to man
possibly something that even accounted
for quantum physics after all these
physics are determine the way neurons
fire and behave
because they determine how everything
behaves
that's why even given the incredible
power of AI I don't think we'll be
uploading a human consciousness within a
hundred lifetimes
so that's it then no creating life for
old bio
but not so fast because I never would go
about building a digital life form in
this way anyway were I tasked with
creating life and given a hypothetical
supercomputer with a limitless
processing power
first I'd see if I could run cyberpunk
2077 at Max settings but then I would
focus on some form of cellular
automation like a Conway's game called
life in Conway's life you start out with
a grid of a predetermined size say 200
by 200 or 10 000 by 10 000 the more the
better cells can be either blank which
are dead or filled which represents
alive you then adjust the number of
cells each turn you kill cells or create
cells based on a number of Simple Rules
birth occurs in dead cells with exactly
three live Neighbors survival occurs
meaning the cell States as it is if a
live cell has two or three live
neighbors and death occurs due to
overpopulation if a live cell has more
than three live neighbors or due to
underpopulation if the live cell has
fewer than two live Neighbors so it
starts out with a seed which is usually
a random selection of living cells
scattered across the grid and then you
watch how it grows and changes over time
according to these rules over multiple
turns this was actually originally done
manually with a pencil and paper on a
small grid which would be a Tyson task
but these days it can be done with a
simulation on a computer and the latter
of course allows for far larger grids
and many more turns resulting in far
more interesting patterns over time
you'll witness cells appear and die
grouped together and seemingly huddle to
form patterns and shapes what's amazing
is that some of these patterns prove
more resilient than others lasting
multiple turns and even moving and
changing shape some even move across the
screen others actually fire projectiles
or give birth to other self-sustaining
patterns
some of the behaviors seem eerily
biological in nature swarming around the
screen like bacteria
and there are many more simulations just
like Conway's life linear is one of the
more interesting of these developed in
2015 by Bert Cham and building upon the
foundation of Conway's life lenier uses
higher resolution patterns and can
produce far more complex Digital Life
forms as a result over 400 different
species have been observed in linear
many of which share traits with real
biological life forms they can reproduce
and even communicate in some ways so
Advanced are these that some people even
call them mathematical life forms
throw in a human hand and you can
achieve even more amazing things imagine
that instead of having a random seed at
the start you manipulate the starting
seed choosing where to place cells by
doing this in Conway's life users have
been able to build entire calculators
even computers that run within life and
actually have their own version of Life
playing within them Conway's life is
therefore cheering complete
now imagine that you had a near
Limitless amount of space for this game
a limitless grid with infinite turns and
unlimited computing power in any time
the population died out a new starting
seed would be introduced at random
over time those calculators and
computers would have to appear naturally
this is the law of chance just as
locking Immortal monkeys in a room with
a typewriter for Infinity necessarily
produces the entire works of Shakespeare
eventually infinite times
so in theory a big enough game of
Conway's life would produce every
possible outcome that would include a
computer running another simulation and
likely far more complex creatures again
this would have to happen if the
simulation were infinite
especially if it weren't life per se but
rather an even more perfect combination
of rules
could we then propose that eventually
such a system might give rise to
something akin to a genuine life form
real intelligence is this how you build
a simulation of life not by Building
Life as we know it but by creating the
conditions for it to emerge naturally
if you believe that creating a digital
human a Consciousness upload is possible
then you must also believe this to be
true because again over infinite time
and space every possibility plays out
but could we create something truly
conscious this way would this thing that
emerged really have sentient to be
self-aware would it really be like us
neuroscientist Guillo tanoni apologies
if I'm mispronouncing that suggests that
Consciousness is not a magical stuff but
rather an emergent property of certain
data patterns just as particles behaving
in a certain way can be wet or can form
a wave the wave is not tied to these
specific particles rather it travels
across particles it's a pattern of data
moving through them a wave can occur in
water in the air or in apple juice
so maybe Consciousness is similar and
it's just a property that arises from
certain patterns it is simply what
information processing of this nature
feels like to us denoni describes his
integrated information Theory or IIT
proposing that Consciousness can arise
from any system with sufficient
differentiation meaning it can adopt
multiple States and integration meaning
it is Unified and interconnected
this He suggests can even be measured as
Phi
with more Phi describing a system that
is more conscious though this is a
controversial viewpoint
Max tegmark remarks that Consciousness
described this way is substrate
independent that means it can arise from
any stuff as long as the stuff exhibits
the right patterns and with that in mind
we could easily assume that
Consciousness could be an emergent
property of a massive simulation in the
vein of Conway's life
but to me there's one glaring Omission
here Free Will more on that in a moment
this is how I would do it though I would
build the system and let it infinitely
iterate put it on Fast forwards and have
the life emerge as a natural consequence
I'd still not understand how the life
works but that's my best bet the biology
of these creatures would interact with
these Simple Rules they might send out
single cells and have them return as a
way to sense the world around them they
might evolve to better navigate the
other creatures that evolve in their
surroundings this might be genuine
mathematical life and yet it would be
entirely incomparable to our own world
the very laws of physics emergent as
they are would be nothing like our own
there would be no way for these beings
to step out into their world they'd be
literally incompatible
there'd be no comparable analogues and
we might not even recognize such life
among the vast sea of data we produce
it would be a rich and entirely
different world we couldn't explore for
these creatures and yet we could
manipulate it from the outside we could
fast forward time for example and allow
their civilizations to become infinitely
more advanced than our own
we would be simultaneously their gods
but also primitive in relation to them
or we could print out that data as a
simple spreadsheet a snapshot of their
entire existence boiled down to a set of
numbers in a super powered Excel
all hypothetically of course but the aim
of this thought experiment was to learn
more about ourselves so now let's take a
look at our own world
is it so different we think of our world
as tangible as corporeal as
three-dimensional nothing like a
spreadsheet of numbers but that is only
how we've evolved to interact with it as
a pattern of information our individual
experiences of the world are entirely
arbitrary what is red we experience the
qualia of red in a specific way but we
can never know if it looks the same to
someone else we know that some people
don't even view red
and we know that there are plenty of
wavelengths of light we don't see at all
like everyone said my last video was
color graded to purple but I couldn't
see it we see solid objects and contrast
even though any given object has far
more space between each molecule than
solid matter we see it that way because
those are the things that we can't pass
through it's what's useful to us as a
species we're simply patterns of data
interpreting other data points on a
cosmic database in a bid to survive
what we see and feel is not in any way
the true interpretation of reality we
could run the same data into a machine
and have it displayed in an entirely
different way
we in the world around us are simply
information this is essentially the
digital physics hypothesis this isn't a
new Theory but I think this is a nice
way to look at it and it does rather
imply that we might be living in a
simulation ourselves not necessarily a
simulation in The Matrix sense or a
virtual reality gaming sense but perhaps
some kind of isolated mathematical
system that exists within a containing
universe
but not necessarily of course if we view
the world in this way we can come
through a few interesting conclusions
about physics and reality
so for example if reality is really just
a database of information then I don't
think time is some magical property I
think it's the accumulation of more
information what we experience as time
passing is simply data being updated if
nothing happened at all if there was
Zero change to the data set we wouldn't
experience time more information in the
data set is future less information is
passed just like you would pause a
simulation on the computer and the
inhabitants would be none the wiser
it's been said that the arrow of time is
tied to entropy
entropy essentially meaning more chaos
in the system
energy transfer in a closed system will
always move from a point of a more
organized state to a more chaotic State
this is entropy blocks of ice will melt
a pool table will go from nicely ordered
as a triangle to balls scattered all
over the table
s erupt and it's been suggested that
this is what gives time its
directionality that an increase in chaos
and disorder is what ensures time does
not run in reverse
but I view this as the same thing as an
increase in information a more chaotic
system is simply a system with more
information patterns are repetitive by
definition I could summarize the shape
and positions of a triangle in pool very
easily and you'd get the gist I could
compress that information balls
scattered all over the table however
offer more information I can't describe
that as succinctly and more to the point
we now have information about how those
balls got to those positions in the past
I could say balls are here now in the
future I can say the balls are here now
and we're here before and this is how
they got there so future equals more
information
time has changed and change is
and with this model of the universe as a
database we can look at space in a
similar way if all there is is
information then all space really is is
the distance between two points more
accurately the relationship between two
data points
space is not an entity unto itself it's
not a stuff and this is in accordance
with relational Theory which stands in
contrast to a substantivalist view of
space as an actual stuff if we accept
the universe to be a data set much like
Conway's life a mathematical system then
relational Theory makes intuitive sense
if we think of Conway's life there's no
actual space between these cells the
space is just describing the difference
between those two points
say you were the only thing in the
universe as a data point floating in The
Ether the only way we have a location is
by considering how our location relates
to other data points if you're a DOT on
an infinite grid there's no way to
describe your location to someone else
that data simply doesn't exist but if
there are two points or three points on
the infinite grid you can at least
describe your relationship to those
points and how that relationship changes
which creates more information or the
error of time there is no here or there
only X number of spaces away from
another object no big or small only
bigger and smaller it's all relative as
Einstein was known to say with a wink
before chugging a beer and speaking of
Einstein I think this is compatible with
his theories space-time is simply the
relationship between two data points in
the past present and future how does
something like dense matter warp space
itself and give us gravity
well in a true data vacuum with no frame
and no point of reference describing my
distance from another data point can
still only be done in relative terms
meaning that we need to look at the
averages of the entire data set meaning
that any update to a single data point
Alters the meaning of every other data
point
trippy right perhaps this also occurs on
localized scales there's other ways we
can make this work but basically we
don't have to think of space as an
actual stuff to think of it as affecting
gravity
the scope of the universe is simply the
gulf between the extremes of the current
data set the furthest points space grows
as the range of data increases
and I think this perspective of the
universe as a data set helps to shed
some light on a little problem I like to
call Quantum superposition I call it
that because that's what it's called
particles at a subatomic Quantum scale
act in ways that seem to defy all logic
among other Madness Quantum particles
can exist in multiple positions at once
which we describe with a probability
wave this describes all the places that
it could be until we measure the
position at which point the particles
appear to collapse into a more final
State choosing one of those outcomes
wave particle duality explains that
particles can behave both as waves and
as particles simultaneously and
frustratingly we can't know both the
position and the momentum of the
particle simultaneously either this is
known as Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle superposition and wave
particle duality are demonstrated by the
infamous double slit experiment which
has baffled viewers of YouTube for
decades now but to recap scientists took
photons light particles and fired them
at a barrier with two slits holes in it
they then observed a screen place behind
their slits and the pattern that formed
against it as the photons Struck it when
the slits were open and no measurements
were taken they saw an interference
pattern appear on the screen
demonstrating that the photons were
acting like waves the patterns emerged
because the possible positions of the
particle interfered with themselves just
like ripples from two Pebbles thrown
into a pond
things took a turn for the strange ER
when they tried to measure which slit
the particle traveled through the simple
Act of measuring changed the behavior of
the photons now two clusters were seen
on the screen behind the slits
suggesting they traveled through as
solid particles no interference patterns
to be found the simple Act of measuring
which side the photons went through
forced them to behave like particles and
not waves force them to choose a
location
like naughty school kids that suddenly
stand still when the teacher turns
around
in some cases the particles were
measured using detectors but there was
concern that the detectors were actually
altering the results so other methods
have been used as well one was to
earmark the photons prior to them being
fired through the slit another was to
use a delayed Choice setup
here scientists would decide randomly
whether or not they were going to
measure which slits the particle went
through only after they'd already gone
through and amazingly the result is that
the behavior of the particles would
still seemingly change as though the
particles knew they were going to be
measured and were thus able to change
their past Behavior this seemed like it
was altering the past based on future
decisions suggesting retro causality in
other words information moving backwards
through time
now retro causality is just one
explanation for this but you know
something is up when information
traveled backwards in time seems like a
reasonable Theory
one of the more accepted explanations
for all of this is the Copenhagen
interpretation this suggests that
particles exist in a state of
superposition meaning multiple positions
at once until they're measured at which
point they collapse into a definite
State why that happens though is enough
to make your head spin and this of
course has led to all kinds of crazy
speculation many people claim that our
Consciousness is altering reality itself
the observer effect and this has even
been used to sell self-help books about
the law of attraction and such nonsense
because of course someone would use this
to try and sell you a shitty ebook
multiversal theories such as the many
worlds interpretation also exist these
posit that every possible scenario plays
out in a separate reality and the one
we're in right now just happens to be
the one that we're experiencing
others suggests that this is evidence
that the universe itself is conscious
this is a huge leap from the information
available
a more sensible explanation is quantum
decoherence this posits that the
weirdness we observe in the quantum
realm is possible thanks to its isolated
nature when we make a measurement of any
kind this represents an interaction with
the system and that forces it to behave
in a sense more than keeping with
classical physics
if we marry this with some other ideas
we can do away with the need for
Consciousness weirdness
you might feel this is an unsatisfactory
explanation however maybe it makes you
feel a bit icky why is that
probably because you've been raised on
classical physics classical physics are
deterministic in nature meaning they are
wholly predictable and even time
reversible so if we could rewind the
simulation we're in right now we'd see
things predictably play out perfectly in
reverse
quantum physics throws all of that out
the window by seemingly being
non-deterministic and even random in
nature
we can't reconcile these two worlds and
so the explanations seem completely
alien to us
but by using what we've already
established I feel we can find a
slightly more satisfactory way of
looking at it because if the only thing
that exists in any real sense is
information then of course we can't
determine facts about things that have
no bearing on any other data the only
things that exist in any real sense
might well be the information required
to create to draw the universe as it is
right now in this moment and this must
necessarily contain all the information
that was required to lead up to this
point especially if we obey the
conservation of information meaning we
can't lose information information can't
be destroyed
anything that doesn't contribute to the
current state of the universe is not a
part of our data set
in other words it doesn't exist
a photon existing in a state of
superposition is in my opinion much like
a variable used in an equation that can
have multiple values without affecting
the outcome of the equation multiple
values satisfy the sum it doesn't need a
fixed determined value and so it is with
a particle in a Quantum State we know
something is there but if it hasn't
reacted with any other data in a
meaningful way then indeed it is part of
an isolated system and as such the
information about its position and
momentum don't exist to us they aren't
available
so if we fed the spreadsheet of the
universe into a supercomputer it could
not extrapolate the position and
momentum of that particle from the
information available thus that data
doesn't exist
404 file not found error the Mad thing
is that once the information has
interacted with the broader system then
its value always was what it's now known
to be because now that information
contributes to the current picture of
the universe as it is
so if that makes some sense to you and
explain some things you might start to
think that maybe we do indeed live in a
simulation like Conway's life but just
wait I actually think that the seeming
randomness of quantum physics can only
be reconciled with classical physics by
accepting that we're in a similar kind
of mathematical simulation and I'm not
about to tell you that being aware of
something collapses the wave function
because that's the computer only
rendering what we're looking at this is
trite turdy Daily Mail pop signs and
lacks an understanding of quantum
physics but even more than I probably do
Consciousness is not even required for
the measurement to cause the collapse
has nothing to do with you or me rather
I'm suggesting that true Randomness can
only come from outside our universe and
in this context I'm describing a certain
kind of Randomness I'll refer to as
non-deterministic Randomness as in
random in the sense it can't be
predicted or extrapolated
and it doesn't have an obvious cause
just as I believe that the choices we
make to be non-deterministically random
we have our reasons but no Theory can
predict what our choices will be if we
accept Free Will whether or not you
believe in Free Will the only way to
describe this Randomness observed in
quantum physics in a deterministic world
is by accepting that it must come from
another set of rules
imagine that you're being existing
within a vast World built within
Conway's life the laws of Conway's life
are deterministic and thus time
reversible we can look at the last
position of Conway's life trace it
backwards and work out the starting
point there's no Randomness in there but
what if a cat ran across the keys of the
computer running the simulation and
introduced some new cells into the mix
within the simulation they would be
truly random there would be no way
whatsoever to reverse the simulation and
get the same outcome no way to have
determined that this would have happened
from the given data set
the cat might still be beholden to
deterministic physical laws within our
universe it wasn't truly random cats do
be sitting on computers after all but
within that Universe it is truly random
and for the sake of convenience because
I wanted to use that example I'm
ignoring the fact that cats have free
will
so it might be that Randomness in our
universe can be explained
deterministically if it comes from
outside our universe perhaps that's how
we answer the problem of outcomes
this problem points out that even if we
can explain why decoherence occurs and
what the uncertainty principle is all
about we don't understand how the
universe decides which values to then
assign to those particles
in other words in the double slit
experiment how does the universe decide
which of the two slits the photons
travel through and we could even code
random cells to appear within Conway's
life and that would still be truly
random within that Universe computers
can't generate truly random numbers they
instead use unpredictable numbers often
based on the internal clock for example
not truly random to worse but random to
those within the simulation because
again that information isn't available
to them so they can't rewind it they
can't extrapolate it and perhaps such
Randomness is similarly coded into our
own universe
to me that's the only way to
satisfyingly explain Free Will and
quantum physics
so are we living in a simulation or what
depending on your definition you could
say almost certainly at least insofar as
any closed system of information is a
simulation any isolated mathematical
system so perhaps a more pertinent
question is does our universe exist
within another universe
there are a lot of people who think it
must do that we're either NPCs
non-playable characters or oblivious
players within a massive computer game
or perhaps a digital prison like The
Matrix
this is simulation Theory it makes more
sense than you might think at first
prominent transhumanist philosopher Nick
postrum argues that the likelihood of us
living in a simulation is actually very
high
if we imagine for the sake of argument
that Humanity someday develops the
ability to create an extremely complex
simulation capable of sustaining life
then we could also assume that we might
do this more than once we might make
hundreds or millions of such simulations
moreover the beings within those
simulations might also develop their own
simulations Millions each meaning that
for any single base reality there are
likely to be billions upon billions of
simulations therefore the likelihood of
us existing in the base reality becomes
improbably small and another question
you might ask then is whether we're
natives of this reality or whether we
are users from a higher plane of
existence
we might imagine that highly Advanced
Immortal humans from the future might
willingly Place themselves into a
simulation like this one with no memory
of their real lives in order to pass the
time some have proposed that this is a
prison for criminals others have
suggested it's a time capsule recreating
points in human history this could even
explain strange coincidences like the
fact that the Moon is the perfect
distance from the Earth to create a
perfect eclipse
this is how a lot of people interpret
simulation Theory but the argument
against this nation is the sheer amount
of processing power it would take to
create such a simulation to simulate
every single atom across an entire
universe it would take as much
processing power and as much energy
potentially as exists in the entire
known universe itself
one counter argument is that simulation
might use tricks to conserve power maybe
those planets that we see in the sky
don't really exist maybe only certain
features of the universe are actually
rendered it might explain why there's no
evidence of life beyond our own planet
but I propose a different answer I
believe that as usual we're being far
too narcissistic and egocentric in our
view of the Multiverse just as we
thought we were at the center of the
solar system and the universe we think
that someone took the time to design us
in their image that the Universe outside
our own is just more us
it's entirely possible if we are indeed
inside a simulation that our containing
universe is nothing like our own
for starters it might be unimaginably
larger than our own with ample
processing power and energy to handle
the task of emulating our existence heck
it could be a trivial task
and it might not look or behave anything
like our own Universe we might be to the
containing Universe what Conway's life
is to our universe entirely different
laws entirely different outcomes
as a side note I think it is somewhat
fair to conclude that the true base
layer Universe might not be predicated
on cause and effect it's a tricky one to
wrap your head around but that does seem
like the only way to really explain how
all this came into being in the first
place it would also provide that first
example of true Randomness that then
filters down through the layers
perhaps this only seems like an issue
because of the universe we're in
we might not be designed at all we might
be emergent patterns of data or at least
our universe might be maybe someone put
some rules into a computer and let it
run and for us to have emerged by chance
within that data set it must be so
unfathomably large as to make us nothing
remarkable
how could our Overlord coders allow
famine and tragedy simple they have zero
conception of those terms no reason to
examine this small selection of cells on
the universal spreadsheet maybe no real
way to interpret the data even if they
did
or perhaps there's no computer even
maybe we're entirely a natural
occurrence what if our universe is
another emergent data set born from
electricity or some analog thereof
dancing across a vast alien Lake what if
the mathematical formula that codes our
entire existence is born from the
interplay of water droplets making their
way down the windshield of some Cosmic
vehicle infinitely more complex than our
own universe but nothing special within
that Universe I mean it's probably not
that one but you get my meaning
perhaps any isolated system any isolated
data set could be considered a universe
maybe it would need a certain amount of
consistency predictability and longevity
in order for complexity to occur over
time
but depending on our definition we could
even argue that Conway's life is already
a universe if it were possible to exist
within that data set and to sense the
cells around us we would know nothing
else it would be the entire limits of
our known reality
and this recalls Max tegmark's
mathematical Universe hypothesis
that any mathematical system can house
the universe
but I'd argue that Conway's life is not
quite a universe here's why
because it doesn't seem quite right does
it how can a simple formula like this be
a universe it just feels wrong but if we
really think about it we can work out
why it feels wrong for starters Conway's
life does not truly add any information
I believe that we could use the current
snapshot of our real Universe in order
to extrapolate its state at any previous
point in time this must be true if
information cannot be destroyed
but the problem with Conway's life is
that we can also extrapolate from the
starting seed in order to calculate
every possible future scenario if we
know the starting cells and the rules of
life then we could calculate every
subsequent turn and it would be the same
every time which means we're not really
adding any information over each turn
the data set is static in this sense
it's more like it's being decompressed
or unzipped
that's why I think a more perfect
iteration of this would need some kind
of random element because this also
raises some obvious concerns about Free
Will in an entirely deterministic time
reversible Universe what space is there
for free will and choice
are our thoughts merely extremely
complex flowcharts to me that seems too
cold and static and kind of pointless
thank you
so in an isolated mathematical system
you would need some kind of Randomness
to come in to add that information
to be dynamic a universe needs the
perfect amount of Randomness enough to
give rise to unpredictable outcomes but
not enough to render the system too
unstable to sustain complexity perhaps
we could only find that perfect balance
over countless iterations and trial and
error so where does that Randomness come
from
one possibility is that there is some
algorithm complex enough that it breaks
down the known laws of the universe that
it can produce a random number perhaps
this is what we know as life some form
of maths that has choice
perhaps that is our purpose in all of
this to add that Randomness to the
unfolding of the universe
and if that seems far-fetched then we
must accept the alternative that the
randomness comes from outside our
universe as I've already proposed if as
guilo tanoni and Max tegmark suggest
Consciousness is simply an emergent
property of certain data patterns like
water that doesn't leave room for free
will because Free Will by definition
must not be deterministic maybe you'd
argue that the two are perfectly
compatible that emergent Free Will could
come from the non-deterministic nature
of quantum Behavior but then we're still
just saying that Consciousness comes
from some mysterious random force it
doesn't really answer the question
and there is some difference in the
randomness of quantum Behavior versus
the potential randomness of free will
because when we make a random choice
we're somehow reacting with the
information available to us but whatever
the case I believe that saying
Randomness in the non-deterministic
sense comes from outside our data set
kind of answers the question it doesn't
fully explain what is causing that
phenomenon but it explains why we can't
answer the question because as substrate
independent entities we have no way of
knowing the nature of the system we're
in
or as I previously suggested there
exists a golden infinitely complex
formula that can produce a truly random
number
which do you think it is
so whether The Human Experience
Consciousness and choice is somehow an
emergent property born out of an
impossibly complex algorithm set on a
loop for infinity or whether it comes
from outside our own Universe it fills
me with some notion that life is somehow
special that it plays an important role
in the universe we might even imagine
that a data set needs an observer of
some kind to be considered a universe
something living inside of it such that
it becomes experiential and not just
hypothetical as Hawkin asks what is it
that breathes fire into the equations
and makes a universe for them to
describe
fun fact I wrote most of this whilst
watching Love Island
anyways guys I hope you found this video
useful and interesting I was a bit
nervous to post it because it's so
different from anything else on this
channel but I just really wanted to put
it out there like I say this isn't
necessarily what I believe it's just a
kind of example of the kind of thinking
I like to do let me know what you think
in the comments and let me know your own
ideas I really can't wait to read your
thoughts it should be an interesting
discussion it's definitely something a
bit different but I do think it's
important to use your brain deeply and
often just like your body
so time to dance
and bye for now
and if you're looking for another way to
try using your brain why not consider
building a website this is a fantastic
project that's fun and creative and
which can lead to all kinds of new
opportunities whether you want a website
to accelerate your business or career or
just as a form of self-expression I
really think that everyone can benefit
from building one
and the easiest and the best way to get
started is with Squarespace today's
sponsors Squarespace is a website
building platform that streamlines the
whole process of building a site so that
anyone can do it with their fluid engine
you can literally drag and drop elements
you want for your site no coding and no
technical know-how required that said
Squarespace also comes packed with all
the features you need to build a fully
functioning website for any purpose
professional or otherwise that includes
Advanced publishing features beautiful
formatting scheduled posts and more it
means a fully integrated commenting
system with threaded comments replies
and likes it means analytics e-commerce
gated members only content for easy
Revenue generation and much more with
plugins you can add even more features
too like inventory management and global
Shipping for your e-commerce the sky's
the limit and it's so easy to get
started so why not give it a go you
never know where it might lead
head over to squarespace.com to learn
more or visit squarespace.com forward
slash bioneer for 10 off your first
domain or website
thanks again to Squarespace thanks to
you guys for watching this far in a huge
video
and bye for now